lauren how are we doing this morning so
uh last fall we had
uh two hard things happen um in sequence
and um one of the things is um
last fall i was picking up my
ten-year-old son from football practice
as we were pulling
out of the parking lot i accidentally
ran over
another little boy with my car
and it was terrible and
um hold on take a breath take a breath
take a breath
you're good anyway
so i find myself struggling
um with anxiety from that
here we are in the football season again
and
um you know i'm finding myself not
wanting to
you know pick him up from practice again
of course
and you know go to the games or anything
and
um so i'm just oh and
the little boy is okay he's
he's all right um now so um just to
throw that in there but um so take a
breath and i'm gonna recap while you're
taking a breath okay so
okay last year during your little boys
football practice
um you're leaving practice and you
accidentally
ran over um another little boy in the
parking lot
and um when people think of that
and again i'm not going to be overly
gratuitous but i've been in these trauma
situations and i want people to
understand what happens in your heart
and mind here
my guess is there were yells and sounds
and things that you saw that people are
not supposed to hear and see is that
right
yeah okay definitely yeah good visuals
yeah there you go and those things
replay themselves
over and over and over right um and then
all of a sudden that
um the boy's okay
right he recovers he's running around
like a normal little boy now
he is okay a miracle really yeah he's
totally fine and the family how do they
hold you responsible do you still
connect with them what's that
relationship like
um no no um they're
um i'm i
forced myself to you know go see see
them afterwards
um just so i could see him normal
you know like um not in that state
and um you know to tell her you know
you know just give her flowers and stuff
um
you know she was nice you know of course
in the moment that was
not good but um uh afterwards
you know she was very nice and um
yeah proud of you for doing that that's
a hard thing to do and um
it's a it's that was an act that will
serve you years to come
seeing him with your own two eyes
running around seeing that family again
um that's gonna pay dividends
years down the road and so now it's
football season again
and you don't want to even go near that
place you don't want to be around that
place and you said there was two things
going on what's the second thing
oh well the second thing was like the
day
after that happened i was you know
obviously having a hard time and
stuff and my husband found out um his
mom had passed away
um unexpectedly and so jeez okay hold on
a second that was
you just you passed that along just
dismissively you're like oh and by the
way
um i went and got burritos at the local
gas station like
no that's a big big family trauma right
it was yeah yes um
it was and so my guess is you didn't get
to grieve at all you turned into
taking care of him taking care of
everybody around is that right
yeah that's exactly right he you know he
looked at me and he just said i
i need you right now i just you know
i knew that he did you know at that
point we knew the little boy was gonna
be okay
and i just was like okay you know so i
just really pushed everything
down and didn't really i don't know i
think i just ran away from it
and so well you ran away in the name of
duty right
um yeah right so if you think if you
think of your feelings
you took yours with two hands and you
compress them
and another word for compress is to
depress right
you yeah depressed them down so that you
could take care of
your husband and your husband's family
and probably
your kids and uh because they lost their
their grandma
and you did a noble thing in a hard
thing
in counseling we call it leakage which
is if you don't deal with past trauma
they will eventually make their way out
usually at a real inopportune time they
don't ever go away
right and lucky for you and i'm saying
this on purpose
lucky for you they're coming out a year
later
and they're coming out in a situation
that i think that you
could you're gonna be able to rally your
heart and mind around
and heal from okay
um so tell me about uh the intrusive
thoughts
what pops into your head when you're
driving down the street when you pull
into a grocery store parking lot tell me
about that
uh just i think just
i don't know like if i feel a bump
you know under the car or something here
yeah your whole
body just floods right yeah yeah just
you know
heart rate just sometimes they feel like
oh this is a little dangerous you know
yeah yeah anyway you know i just
i do feel like i have like these anxiety
attacks um and then
you know eventually they kind of fade
and
i'm okay but you know i just i feel like
i don't want to go to that parking lot
again and you know
i feel like i'm not supporting you know
i don't know yeah totally like i'm not
so let me one last question i've got for
you guys i'm kind of wrapping up what we
can do here wrapping my head around what
what i can recommend for you do you
still
wake up and i'm saying still because i
100 know i've met with a thousand people
in your situation
uh that's probably an over overstatement
but
um do you still wake up in the middle of
the night
or has that gone away not not
some not waking up as much um you know
when you wake up is your heart racing
already or are you are you able to wake
up and
are you able to sleep a full night i'm a
yeah i'm i'm sleeping sleeping okay
that's
awesome awesome good yeah okay
all right so here's um here's a couple
of things some of this you've probably
heard me do on the radio before
and but i want to do it with you and
then i'm going to give you kind of a
game plan on a road map is that cool
yeah that sounds great okay here's the
first thing
you have to decide
and only you can decide this okay you
have to decide that
this is not going to be your identity
and that you don't want to keep
wrestling with this
and until you decide that your brain
is going to continue to try to take care
of you and everyone around you
by sounding every alarm it has every
time it gets in a situation that it
remembers is dangerous
and often people in your situation
sentence themselves
to a life in prison
for an accident yeah
until you pardon yourself
until you say all right i've
i have beat myself up for a year and i'm
ready for this not to be ident my
identity i'm ready to not be the lady
who ran over the little boy
i'm ready to be the awesome mom who
loves my kid
the awesome wife who loves my husband
the awesome community member who has ups
and downs in her life like everybody
else
and when you're ready for that to be
your identity not the worst thing that's
happened to you that you did
and let me be honest if you are texting
and emailing and
trying to eat fast food in your lap at
the same time
i don't care what happened happened and
now we're a year later
and so i want you to decide
that you're gonna let yourself out of
jail okay
because by not letting yourself out of
jail you are making sure that you will
never heal
the people who love you will never heal
and the people around you will never
heal
so i want you to say i forgive me and
now we're going to be about healing
okay i want you to close your eyes
right we're here on the phone and anyone
listening to this
podcast i want you to close your eyes
and i want you to picture
i don't know um a monkey on a motorcycle
okay just a monkey on a motorcycle and i
wanted to have like a yellow hat
curious george style and i want you to
um
the i don't know i want the the
motorcycle to have like a little side
cart on it right
you got that in your mind yeah okay so
open your eyes
you have just proven to me and to all
the people listening to this and there's
a lot of people listening
that you can when you decide to you can
control your thoughts
and so what you're going to have to do
is this you're going to have to retrain
your
brain to not focus on those moments
and it's going to sound something like
this you're going to be driving along
and you're going to hit a pothole
and your body is going to remember
you're amygdala your brain is going to
remember
oh i remember what that means and it's
going to flood you it's going to make it
when your stomach's all warm and your
heart starts racing
that cortisol and adrenaline is going to
dump into your body your hands are going
to get sweaty
and you're gonna remember that little
boy's foot you're gonna remember
something unique about that situation
and i want you in that moment to go nope
right and then here's what i want you to
do i want you to remember him
at his house playing after he was okay
you get to choose which one of those
thoughts you dwell on
and your brain has a vested interest in
you dwelling on the bad stuff because it
doesn't want that to happen again
and it's not gonna happen again because
you're gonna be a safe driver you're
going to
recognize that was a one in a trillion
accident
the kids shoot out from behind people in
parking lots all the time in ball field
you know ball field parking lots
and that you're going to choose to think
of something positive about him and my
promise to you is over time you will
readjust that default setting
in your brain okay it will recognize oh
it doesn't need me to protect
myself from that anymore the second
thing is
i want you to go to that parking lot
with a friend that you trust
when there's nobody there on a sunday
afternoon
on a monday morning and i want you to
practice
driving in and parking and backing up
and parking
but listen in the nerd world they call
it exposure therapy
right i don't think you need a therapist
to do this i think you need to get a
friend with you
you got to have somebody and probably
not your husband because he's going to
try to teach you what you're doing wrong
you need a friend just to be with you
right
and i want you to go there and back up
and pull in
and then i want you to back up and pull
in and if you need to get out of the car
and take a walk
great you're gonna have a friend with
you if you need to yell and scream and
cry and swear and do all the things
great you have a friend with you if
y'all need to jam on some old motley
crew records whatever you'll have to do
in that moment
but i want you to practice and i want
you to do this a couple of times
and then when you feel comfortable and
you're never a comfortable is not a good
word when you feel
safe not comfortable because it's going
to be uncomfortable for a while
i want you to drive your son to practice
and park as far away from possible at
the very very back of a parking lot
okay and you are going to slowly ease
your way back into this and when you do
you're going to constantly be monitoring
your thoughts for truth
right okay i want when you have those
feelings that you're a bad driver you're
a terrible person what kind of idiot
neighbor or mom would fill in the blank
i want you to demand evidence from those
feelings because they lie to you
okay okay they lie to you
and so in review i want you to decide
and this is this is on your timetable
but my guess is
your husband loves you your kids love
you and they're ready to have their mom
back
and my guess is that you're ready to
have you back
you decide that this is not going to be
your identity you are not the worst
thing that you've ever done
you're not and that you want to heal
you're going to let yourself out of the
prison that you've placed yourself
okay number two i want you to start
practicing controlling those thoughts
and it's going to be a pain
and it's going to be hard but and it's a
daily thing
right and then the number three i want
you to get a friend or two
make an event of it and i want you to go
when that parking lot is empty and
practice driving in and backing up
until you can do it to where your heart
rate is just normal
and then the final thing is i want you
to take your son to practice and park as
far away from everybody as possible in
the far corner of that parking lot
and you're going to slowly ease yourself
back into this okay
very few people will be watching and
staring at you
and you think they're all going to be
remembering you as the lady that did xyz
they're not they're worried about their
own drama their own election
nonsense or their own covet they're
worried about that stuff
okay yeah so when i tell you those four
things how does that hit you in your
heart
um scary initially
um but oh
yeah scary but um that i
i think that would help just you know i
can see how that would
would help to go there with nobody there
and it's not so similar you know and
try to kind of work through that and you
know
controlling my thoughts and not letting
hey lauren get away from me
lauren you've got to let you off the
hook
you are the last person to forgive you
and today is that day
okay so when
we get off this call i can hear it on
you
i can hear it on you when we get off
this call
the first thing i want you to do is to
go into your bedroom or go into a home
office or go into your garage and i want
you to write yourself a letter that says
um i forgive you i want you to address
it to you
you got it okay
yeah you do not deserve to carry this
around you for the rest of your life
it happened you've been forgiven you've
got to forgive you
okay yeah that's where healing starts
in this together yeah yeah
awesome yep so here's what i want you to
do
after you go to the parking lot a few
times i want you to email me back i want
you to call me
and let me know how that went i want to
know how your heart was racing
how your friend was cheering you on or
making fun of you if they're a friend
like i have
and laughing all i want you i want to
know how that went but i know you can do
it
and for crying out loud lauren you've
got to forgive you
and everyone listening to this
everybody is involved in accidents
everyone does things that they wish they
could have back
they all make mistakes and we just live
in this world where nobody forgives each
other anymore especially ourselves
and that's got to stop because you just
live out of your pain then you live out
of these bricks in your backpack that
you're the only one putting them in
there
so lauren set the backpack down write
yourself a letter today
that says dear loren this happened then
i'm sorry
and i forgive you you're a good mom
you're a good wife you're going to heal
from this and the healing starts today
with letting you off the hook